using just their bare hands and plastic
bowls these villagers are trying to
clear up one of the worst oil spills in
the area in living memory and this is
not just any area it's one of the
world's largest mangrove forests and a
natural habitat for thousands of species
in wildlife but now the habitat looks
like this oil swirling in water as far
as the eye can see more than 70 square
kilometers of the forest are
contaminated government officials fear a
disaster in the making especially for
the region's rare dolphins beside the
Dolphins fish resources of the area will
be affected and the oil is not going to
stay in one place it's moving far away
due to tidal waves when the tide goes
out the water will recede so we're
surveying how much of the area will be
affected solid you buddy rescuers have
now salvaged the stricken tanker a navy
boats and other government vessels are
said to be on their way to help clear up
the oil local people say they have
neither the technology or the know how
to tackle a slick of this size for now
they are using booms to contain the
spill but activists say the biodiversity
of the area could be destroyed if the
effort is not speeded up soon